Vous contestez le fait que ensemble soit
devant vous à 20 000 voix à peu près le
contexte parce que c'est contestable
voilà c'est à dire que il y a un espèce
de tripatouage pour essayer d'arranger
les résultats
en fait il y a très simple il y a des
candidats qui ne sont pas comptabilisés
dans l'anus alors qu'ils sont soutenus
par la nuque depuis le début lesquels
polyniaque et potier Dominique petit
Moselle Hervé pardon Hervé Solignac en
Ardèche excusez-moi et puis d'autres qui
sont à l'inverse des dissidents en
marche et qui sont comptabilisés dès le
départ dans le corps normal donc on fait
des choses d'un côté on fait pas de
l'autre nous on est pour nous à 26,8%
des voix donc on est devant parce que
Dominique Poitiers lui a pas voulu de
l'investir de l'année peut-être mais il
est soutenu par la Nupe et vous verrez
que si la nuit vous verrez qu'il siègera
dans un des groupes de l'anus donc c'est
encore une fois Monsieur Darmanin pas à
l'inverse fait des inclus des candidats
d'en match qui ne sont pas qui sont
lissantes en tout ça c'est fait pour
essayer d'arranger les résultats
les résultats quand quand vous êtes
quand vous comptez des choses à côté
vous les comptez pas de l'autre tout ça
pour finalement à 20000 voix près ça
vous permet de dire commenter
l'actualité en disant que ensemble est
en tête quand c'est l'anus qui est en
tête bah ouais c'est sans douteillage
d'un rangement on va dire si vous
préférez à terme plus modéré bref en
tout cas c'est quelque chose qui ne
reflète pas la réalité parce que la
réalité excusez-moi c'est ça qui est
plus important ce matin c'est pour
est-ce que vous allez porter un recours
officiellement est-ce que vous avez
comptabilisation des choses ça va pas
changer le résultat mais ça nous on
tient à le dire parce que non seulement
c'est un excellent résultat qui
transforme j'allais dire ce que l'essai
en réussite c'est lorsque nous avons le
faire avec l'anus mais j'allais dire
aussi c'est le plus mauvais résultat
d'un président de la République au
premier tour de législatives voilà
jamais en prison il fait moins de 32% et
ils sont dans une grande difficulté
parce que non seulement nous pouvons
être majoritaire mais il y a quasiment
une chose à mon avis
c'est qu'ils vont pas avoir de majorité
de toute façon donc ils se retrouvent
une situation très complexe c'est une
défaite de premier tour pour Monsieur
Macron et une défaite encore plus grande
du Premier ministre qui je vous rappelle
madame borne et la chef de la majorité à
mon avis je vois mal comment elle va
poursuivre son travail mais juste si
elle remporté
majoritaire il y a pas de problème façon
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sera Premier ministre
mais si c'est pas le cas je le vois mal
comment une chef de la majorité qui
prépare une élection pour une première
minis sert à ça pour avoir une majorité
qui ne l'a pas je vois pas très bien
comment tout ça pourra se faire on verra
pas les projections elle va avoir une
majorité même si c'est pas pour vous
s'il y en a pas une majorité absolue
elle ne pourra pas poursuivre son
travail
c'est une analyse politique que je fais
je vous disais dans tous les cas mon
avis madame bornes ne sera pas la
première ministre par la suite d'abord
une chose parce qu'elle échoue et
deuxième chose de manière un peu plus
certaine parce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
sera Premier ministre
[Musique]